all right let's take some phone calls
617 830 for 750 is the number who's on
the phone first hello there David yes
this is David who's this this is my come
from bob lutz florida of here a
beautiful sunny day in the trailer park
let me tell you all right what can we
buy Michael I'm sorry I interrupted you
go right ahead no what's your question
well my questions dish man I've been
watching a lot of you on the internet
here and I know you got that the new guy
they're helping out real cool guy good
choice happy for you they're good but uh
you know I we kind of have an affection
for Louis we still love him and probably
speaking for a lot of people lady ought
to do just a couple updates on how Louis
is doing known his new adventure I know
it's got to be some more south down here
near me maybe who knows own that there's
a opening at the gas station he wants to
come work with me yeah I know I will
pass that message along to him um but
you know the the thing is Louis has not
yet made it to the south he's still in
Massachusetts and he said it could take
him actually somewhere around six to
nine months to figure out where it is
that he is going to end up so Lewis is
doing well I spoke to him yesterday he
seems to be in good spirits although I
think he's focusing more on sort of
sleeping in and video gaming right now
than then job prospects you know but
that's exactly what we do down the
trailer park David sit around all day we
get a check from the government with why
we want to stay Democratic of course you
know we sit around and play video games
with the money they send us and
sometimes appear when there's extra it's
a beautiful life sitting here my white
t-shirt and uh cutoff jean shorts able
to tell you I'm sure I'm sure everything
you told me is absolutely true in
exactly the way it is down there I I
don't know why you would ever exaggerate
about that okay thank you so much for
the call really really appreciate it
warby parker is offering a free five day
home try-on to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses i personally
wear warby parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing